chocolate is good for your teeth it's my
cup of coffee we got four of the best
chocolate ice creams here start with hey
and see how you like it
with no other dark ice cream around I
would enjoy this nutty woody appliques
chocolatey
is there a hint of anything in that
raspberry maybe I should have all right
we're gonna move on to be it's in old
fashions oh that reminds me of chocolate
of another time
alright run to see if I were blindfolded
I would not think this is chocolate it's
a hybrid of some kind run 2d which I've
got a feeling you're gonna like that's
good this one I would eliminate all
right let's see what see is that you've
eliminated as your favorite
Morgenstern's is a very trendy place
right now in New York alright so you're
going back to hey now okay
hey is your favorite no no no no all
right let's see big gay ice cream that's
gonna be a problem back in the district
that's apt to we're down to BMD the
marshmallow is kind of alienating my
standard is unadulterated this is my
breakfast I'm thinking you're leaning
Dee but I don't want to prejudge it D it
looks like it's the art well let's see B
Breyers
so the Pelosi favor turned out to be
Jenny's what did you like I'm all with
UV which I thought easily the best
clarity of the flavor on that one is
pretty absolutely well and then of
course there's always though there's a
little bit of okay on this one but and
now that's melty it's basically a
milkshake well I would tell you this is
one of my more enjoyable interviews